thanks to audible for keeping legal
eagle in the air oh my gosh I have so
much work to do today well let me read
one more article by the mainstream media
fake news before I get started
testimony torpedoes Republican defenses
of Trump Trump's defenses are almost
entirely gone
Trump has no defense after sunland
testimony that can't be right
cannon hey legal eagles it's time to
think like a lawyer because Republican
and Democratic positions on this whole
impeachment hearing have been changing
over time and I think it's worthwhile
going over the Republican impeachment
defenses to see if they hold any legal
water quick disclaimer of course the
facts are fluid and they are changing
multiple witnesses are testifying every
week so some of the factual issues here
that I'm going to discuss I'm sure are
going to change but I wanted to take
some time to focus on some of the legal
issues that are implicated by these
impeachment hearings I'm going to try to
do my best to steal man these arguments
in other words I'm going to try to give
the Republican defenses in the best
light possible to avoid attacking straw
men and dealing with the best possible
version of those particular defenses
some of these defenses are better than
others it's a bit of a moving target
though because different Republicans
have focused on different defenses there
isn't exactly a unified front on this
but that being said let's dig into the
main defenses that the Republicans are
using in this impeachment inquiry
so the first impeachment defense
probably boils down to no quid pro quo
or in other words the call was perfect
there's a rumor out they want the first
conversation it was beautiful it was
just a perfect conversation this is
largely the preferred defense of
President Trump and that he tends to
tweet this out with some frequency this
also appeared to be the early favored
defense of the Republicans that has
largely evaporated you still see it a
little bit but it's not the favored
defense at the time the argument is that
as a factual matter there was no quid
pro quo between the United States and
Ukraine I didn't do it there was no quid
pro quo senators and all of these other
people have actually done what they're
accusing me of doing which I didn't do
as the president often tweets
and says and public read the transcript
whether you believe that the transcript
is sufficient to show a quid pro quo
evidencing solicitation of a bribe or
whether you believe that the transcript
demonstrates that the call was in fact
perfect as the president says is a
factual matter for you to decide in a
variation of this argument was used in
the questioning of lieutenant-colonel
vin Minh by representative Radcliffe who
pointed out that no witness in the
depositions as part of the impeachment
inquiry had ever used the word bribery
in an impeachment inquiry that the
Speaker of the House says is all about
bribery where bribery is the impeachable
offense no witness has used the word
bribery to describe president problems
conduct
none of them instead that witnesses had
used the phrase quid pro quo bribery is
the ultimate conclusion in other words
it is a legal conclusion that the
Democrats are attempting to prove if the
analogy to being a prosecutor holds and
it would be improper to ask the fact
witnesses about an ultimate legal
conclusion that's not what fact
witnesses are for and while reasonable
Minds can differ about the conclusions
that one draws from the facts that have
been elicited thus far and I leave it to
you as to where you think the facts are
going this particular case it does seem
like most Republicans are pivoting away
from the argument that there is no quid
pro quo at all because to believe that
argument you would have to believe that
most of the witnesses that have
testified so far are lying including
Jovanovic Sandlin Holmes Williams Taylor
Volker Kent Hill VIN Minh and John
friggin Bolton they're all Liars in this
particular case and that's a hard
argument to make which is why it seems
to appear that most Republicans have
moved on from no quid pro quo to no
illegal or impeachable quid pro quo in
fact even chief of staff Mick Mulvaney
said in the last press conference that
he gave that there was in fact a quid
pro quo and that quid pro quos happen
all the time we do that all the time
with foreign policy and in fact that
this particular quid pro quo was
conditioned partially on an
investigation into the Biden's Gordon
Sandlin said in his testimony that there
was in fact an explicit quid pro quo he
straight-out
said it was there a quid pro quo as I
testified previously
with regard to the requested White House
call and the White House meeting the
answer is yes now House Minority Leader
Kevin McCarthy takes a slightly more
nuanced path when he argued that the
Ukrainians got everything that they
wanted so there was no quid pro quo
that's not exactly the same thing as
arguing that there was no quid pro quo
except to say that there was no ultimate
transfer of a thing of value which is a
slightly different argument that we'll
get to in just a second Ben Shapiro
points out an interesting nuance on
Twitter when he says the question for
Sandlin today isn't whether Trump
withheld aid in exchange for
investigations we already knew that the
question is whether Trump's intent was
to get Biden in anticipation of 2020 or
to investigate 2016 activities out of
concern for corruption even if the
latter was based on bad information and
conspiracism promoted by Giuliani and
this is true in a criminal prosecution
sense I I don't often agree with Ben
Shapiro but I think this is an
interesting if nuanced point that deals
with the mens rea a defense to
impeachment which we'll talk about in
just a second but I do want to drop a
footnote that I want you to think about
which is that it's not an either/or
proposition that the president's
motivation was either to get dirt on the
Biden's for his own personal gain or to
investigate corruption in Ukraine it's
not necessarily the case that he had
only one motivation and the legal
implications of this mixed potential
motive are very very interesting and
that brings me to the next argument it's
all hearsay the Trump administration and
supporters have been fairly consistent
in arguing that the evidence that's been
elicited so far has been hearsay
testimony in that it relies on
out-of-court statements it's all hearsay
you can't get a parking ticket
conviction based on hearsay the
whistleblower didn't hear the phone call
now I have done an entire video on the
nature of hearsay evidence as it regards
these impeachment hearings but suffice
it to say while there is a grain of
truth in these arguments just because
something is hearsay doesn't mean it's
number one admissible and number two bad
evidence and the public shorthand of
thinking of hearsay evidence as being
second in her third hand information is
not necessarily coextensive with the
legal definition
and often hearsay is powerful evidence
and it depends on the particular
circumstances whether particular
evidence particularly hearsay evidence
is good evidence or bad evidence it
depends on whether that evidence is
corroborated it depends on the nature of
the circumstances themselves and it
depends on whether the circumstances
would allow that hearsay evidence in or
not now there are arguments to be made
that to the extent the information is
hearsay there are all kinds of
exceptions to the hearsay rule there
using every day in court to allow that
information to be admitted into evidence
sometimes hearsay evidence is incredibly
strong I would argue that things like
business records in the form of emails
or video or testimony of the accused who
admits to a crime all of which are
considered hearsay but are admissible in
court because they are very strong
pieces of evidence but admittedly
sometimes hearsay is particularly weak
it depends on the nature of the evidence
of the nature of the circumstances in
that particular case now I will point
out that in these proceedings there's a
bit of what lawyers we call an unclean
hands problem in that the people who
have first-hand knowledge of what the
president said and what the president
did are being prevented from testifying
in these proceedings and I think the
Democrats would argue that for example
if the mob intimidates a witness into
not testifying that member of the mob
shouldn't be able to then argue about
the lack of witnesses the testifying
against them and as Neal Katyal has
argued on Twitter the only reason that
we don't have the first-hand knowledge
witnesses is because Trump blocked them
from testifying that itself is
impeachable and as time goes on perhaps
we will get more testimony from those
individuals who had first-hand knowledge
of the actual instructions that
President Trump may or may not have
given and on November 20th
Gordon Sandland who did have some
first-hand interactions with the
President and first-hand knowledge of
the events described did testify that
apparently the entire State Department
led by Mike Pompeo and chief of staff
Mulvaney did know about the explicit
quid pro quo you've testified and that
Mulvaney was aware
of this quid pro quo of this condition
that the Ukrainians had to meet that is
announcing these public investigations
to get the White House meeting is that
right yeah a lot of people were aware of
it and including about including mr.
Mulvaney correct which brings me to the
next big defense which is that the aid
the military and financial aid that was
allegedly conditioned on investigations
into the Biden's was in fact released or
for short the Sideshow Bob defense this
is the defense that was made famous by
the Simpsons and arguing that attempted
crime is not really a crime victim of a
crime I didn't even commit murder now
honestly what is that do they give a
nobel prize for attempted chemistry
Tuesday I know this may come as news to
many of you out there but attempted
crime is in fact a crime and
unfortunately for many of you next time
you are pulled over by the police you
can't try to get out of it by offering
the police a bribe and then claim that
it wasn't attempted bribery because the
police officer didn't accept the bribe
that you offered that will get you in a
lot of trouble hashtag not legal advice
now I think most people intuitively
understand that attempted crime is still
in fact a crime in and of itself but
this argument in particular in the
context of bribery makes absolutely no
sense solicitation of a bribe is a
federal crime under 18 USC two a one
particularly subsection B to federal
bribery occurs when a public official
seeks a thing of value in exchange for
some official act or Duty it doesn't
rely on the person who is the target of
the solicitation actually giving the
politician in question the thing of
value it's all in the ask arguably there
isn't such a thing as attempted
solicitation of bribery in the context
of someone who has asked for a bribe in
that particular case the act has been
consummated there's no attempt there is
an actual violation of the law so here
the argument is that President Trump
sought an investigation into a political
rival in exchange for releasing a hold
on funds that Congress appropriated
punctuated in these lens
the transcript readout where President
Trump talks about the aide and then says
I would like you to do us a favor though
along those lines nikki Haley says it
didn't succeed so it was absolutely okay
the Ukrainians never did the
investigation and the president released
the funds I mean when you look at those
there's just nothing impeachable there
the main argument being here that
because the four hundred million dollars
in aid was in fact released that is
evidence that there was no conditional
hold on it in the first place and
therefore no quid pro quo and it
certainly is potential evidence of that
particular argument the counter-argument
there is that based on the timeline that
the aid was released only after Politico
did it's famous article on this
particular potential quid pro quo after
the whistleblower had already come
forward and after the house had started
investigating the whistleblower that
based on that timing the actual release
of the funds is not as exculpatory as
the administration may want it to seem
and as far as I know there doesn't
appear to be a strong counter narrative
as to why the aid was held in the first
place Gordon Sandlin says he reached out
to the administration for an answer as
to why there was a hold and no one
including up until the present day ever
provided him with a reason for why there
was a hold on these Ukrainian funds
which was particularly important because
the aid was going to expire at the end
of September if it wasn't released based
on the Congressional Budget arey rules
the best defense is that it was somehow
related to anti-corruption measures
which we'll talk about in just a second
but that brings me to the next argument
which is that Ukrainians didn't feel any
pressure this is a slight variation on
the aid was released argument now it
remains to be seen to what extent the
Ukrainians knew or thought that the four
hundred million dollars in aid was being
deliberately withheld on condition of
investigations into the Biden's there
are conflicting witnesses on both sides
but I think it's unanimous in that
everyone knew that the aid wasn't
delivered and that there was some kind
of delay on the four hundred million
dollars in aid now some including Mick
Mulvaney have argued that the president
withheld the aid to ensure that it was
put to good use but it's worth pointing
out
that the president doesn't have
authority to withhold congressionally
appropriated funds the 1974
Congressional Budget and impoundment
Control Act at 31 USC 1512
states that the president can only
impound funds under limited
circumstances and for no more than 45
days because congressional power is at
its zenith when you're talking about the
budget congressional appropriations
Congress has the power of the purse and
the funds would have expired if not
released by the end of September because
of the way that the congressional budget
works the relevant federal budget was
passed in September of 2018 a year prior
and in February of 2019 the Trump
administration said it was releasing the
aid to Ukraine and it wasn't until
almost the entire year after it was
passed that the Trump administration
actually released the appropriated funds
which I probably don't need to tell you
is far longer than the 45 days that the
impoundment Control Act allows the
president to delay and as to whether the
Ukrainians actually felt the pressure or
not it actually doesn't matter for the
crime of bribery Elly missed all makes
this point in a great article in the
nation which I will link to below he
talks about the difference between the
crime of bribery and the crime of
extortion bribery or at least in this
case solicitation for bribery does not
require that the recipient feel any
particular pressure whereas the crime of
extortion does require undue pressure
being levied against the victim and that
forcing them to do something as a result
of that which takes me to the next
offense which is too bad to crime AKA
quid amateur quo in the world of attempt
it doesn't matter if you are stopped
beforehand or are so inept as to not be
able to actually consummate the criminal
act contemplated or that the victim is
unaware that the criminal acts are going
on what matters are whether you have the
requisite intent and whether you take a
step in furtherance of that particular
act so for example if you are wearing
ski masks with the intent to rob a bank
it doesn't matter if you are arrested
before you get to the bank that's
attempted bank robbery or if you go into
a bank and ask the teller for money
gunpoint and she says no and you don't
get any money that's also attempted bank
robbery
so from in a criminal law perspective it
doesn't actually matter if you're not
good enough or competent enough to
actually complete the crime that you are
accused of what matters is that you
attempted to do it and that you have the
requisite mens rea or corrupt intent to
be able to do it of course as we've
discussed in the world of solicitation
of bribery all that's required is that
the ask be made it doesn't actually
require that the thing of value that was
sought actually be transferred there
really is no attempt in this particular
context it's the full crime itself so
whether the people who are being accused
here are competent enough or not is
beside the point at least as it regards
general criminal law which brings me to
the next defense the Ukrainians didn't
pay up this is a variation on the actual
crime itself was not completed argument
and this was the focus of representative
Jim Jordan during the questioning of
Gordon Sandlin on November 20th
representative Jordan focused on the
fact that allegedly President Trump had
extorted the Ukrainians to investigate
the Biden's and to do an investigation
into the CrowdStrike Ukrainian servers
and he focused on the idea that because
the Ukrainians didn't pay up for what
was part of the quid pro quo that
therefore there was no underlying crime
you know what a quid pro quo is I do
this for that right looks to me like
Ukraine got that three times a week
there was no this there was we we didn't
do anything or excuse me they didn't
have to do anything the argument goes
that effectively no harm no foul because
the Ukrainians got what they wanted and
they didn't have to investigate the
Biden's again the problem with this
argument is that the idea of attempted
solicitation of bribery is a little bit
inchoate and the no harm no foul
argument sort of breaks down when you
compare it to an analogy to something
that we can all agree would be
absolutely solicitation for a bribe so
imagine if you had a politician who is
on a city council for example and says
to a local developer I will approve your
project if you give
a million dollars into my bank account
well we can all agree that that is
solicitation of a bribe it doesn't
actually matter if the developer pays
the million dollars or eventually goes
to the newspaper reveals it and then the
development is approved the fact that
the politician asked for a million
dollars is the improper Act and is the
consummation of the crime of
solicitation of bribery and here
representative Jordan is probably
correct that the Ukrainians didn't have
to do the ultimate things that were
asked of them the factual evidence
appears to show that the Ukrainians were
in active talks with the State
Department to eventually make an
announcement there were negotiations
back and forth as to what the
announcement was going to say and during
the July 25th call president Solinsky
says that he is going to do it
effectively the damage was done and the
ask was made and on November 20th Gordon
Sandlin testified that in exchange for
the official act of actually releasing
the four hundred billion dollars in aid
the Ukrainians only had to announce
investigations into the Biden's they
actually didn't have to do the
investigations into the Biden's I never
heard mr. Goldman anyone say that the
investigations had to start or had to be
completed the only thing I heard from
mr. Giuliani or otherwise was that they
had to be announced in some form and
that form kept changing and now it's
publicly announced publicly now it's
probably worth pointing out that the
aide was released only after the Trump
administration allegedly got caught and
as possible that there are other
explanations there could be other
evidence here and that the timing here
is only a coincidence but so far the
White House hasn't really provided that
evidence or provided an alternative
narrative all right that takes us to the
no men's raya defense and the variation
the too dumb to crime defense now some
crimes have a very specific intent
requirement sometimes called mens rea a'
in other words a lot of criminal laws
require not only do you do the act that
is considered criminal the actus rheya
but you also have to have the mental
state that goes along with that
particular act in this particular case
president Trump needs to have had these
specific intent to solicit a bribe
proving mens rea 'it sounds hard it
requires proving
the mental state of another person and
often times that is very difficult but
it's also something that the criminal
justice system is very very familiar
with you use the witnesses other actions
and statements to show state of mind
here for the most part I think we're
talking about 18 USC 201 B 2 which is
the solicitation of a bribe now the
caveat here is as always
impeachment does not require proving
beyond a reasonable doubt that someone
committed a crime the burden for
impeachment is not the same as the
burden for a criminal prosecution
impeachment is a political device and
high crimes and misdemeanors can often
mean whatever Congress says it means
this particular statute does provide a
good definition of generally what courts
look for in terms of solicitation of a
bribe now the jury instructions for
federal bribery state that at least when
you're talking about trying to bribe an
official the defendant must have
promised offered or given money or a
thing of value to the public official
with a deliberate purpose of influencing
an official act of that person the
analogy being that when you're talking
about the solicitation of a bribe it's
the other way around the public official
is asking to be influenced in exchange
for some other official Act but that is
the general mens rea of the intent
requirement that the prosecutor would
have to show in order to prove
solicitation of a bribe now here on
November 20th Gordon sunland's said that
the president conditioned a White House
meeting on the Ukrainians providing the
investigation into the Biden's and the
Ukrainian CrowdStrike server but sawn
hland also testified that he never heard
the specific words that the four hundred
million dollars in military aid was
conditioned on the Biden investigation
he said that was his conclusion from all
the instructions that he received from
McMullen II and Mike Pompeo now contrary
to what you see on TV criminals rarely
say the actual explicit words that by
themselves are sufficient to prove the
actual crime generally prosecutors have
to prove that with circumstantial
evidence now also contrary to what you
see on TV circumstantial evidence can be
very very strong DNA evidence is
considered circumstantial evidence and
in fact if this were a criminal
prosecution the jury would get an
instruction from the judge that says
circumstantial evidence is as strong if
not stronger as
direct evidence and all circumstantial
evidence means is something that is not
by itself directly sufficient to prove
the crime itself or in this case the
mental state now in this particular case
the circumstantial evidence of the
potential mens rea F for solicitation of
bribery would include the July 25th call
with President Solinsky the July 26th
call with Gordon Sandlin the fact that
Rudolph Giuliani was a go-between even
though he's not a member of the
government and everything else that was
said and done as between Sandlin and the
members of the State Department in fact
Gordon's onlin testified that he cleared
everything with Mulvaney bolton and
Pompeyo and he assumed that if it came
from those people that they came from
orders from the President himself on the
other hand defenders of the
administration would point to other
circumstantial evidence that they would
claim as evidence of lacking the
required mens rea a' to effectuate a
solicitation of bribery and in fact
gordon Sandlin says that after Bill
Taylor famously texted as I said on the
phone I think it's crazy to withhold
security assistance for help with a
political campaign in a September 9th
phone call with the president that
potentially raises the questions that
Bill Taylor raised I just asked him an
open-ended question mr. chairman what do
you want from Ukraine I keep hearing all
these different ideas and theories and
this and that what do you want and it
was a very short abrupt conversation he
was not in a good mood and he just said
I want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo well you can argue that the
president explicitly saying that he
doesn't want a quid pro quo is
exculpatory evidence and shows that he
lacks the requisite mens rea uh you can
also argue given the timeline that it's
actually supports a potential cover-up
from the president that given the
timeline that the political article had
already revealed the potentially
improper hold on Ukrainian foreign
assistance and the fact that even Bill
Taylor was saying it was crazy to
condition the aid on the Ukrainians
investigating the Biden's that this call
and the statement that President Trump
made to Gordon Sandlin is actually
evidence that he was backtracking and
trying to cover up his tracks we can go
both ways that's the issue with
circumstantial evidence at Cannes
or one narrative but it can also support
a different narrative as well and I will
leave it to you as to whether you
believe the president intended the
exchange for his own purpose or for an
official purpose of the government which
brings me to the next potential defense
which is that the president controls
foreign policy and it would be improper
to impeach him over a foreign policy
decision now there is certainly some
truth to this the president has almost
all of the power for foreign policy he
is the commander-in-chief of the Armed
Forces and he controls almost every
decision when it comes to foreign policy
really Congress has the power to declare
war ratify treaties and appropriate
funds when it comes to foreign policy
but that's really about it
the executive is really in control of
foreign policy now there is a dispute
about whether a constitutionally
enumerated power can give rise to a
crime or to impeachment when the
President does it that means that it is
not illegal by definition exactly but
most constitutional scholars agree that
even an official act that is enumerated
by the Constitution can give rise to
impeachment if not criminal prosecution
that being said you would imagine that
given that the president has vast
foreign policy powers that you would be
very very reluctant to impeach the
president over something that he or she
has plenary authority over in this case
setting foreign policy or removing an
ambassador and there's no doubt that
interactions with Ukraine touch on
foreign policy power but just because
you have a right doesn't mean that you
can escape the repercussions of
exercising that right in the same way
that you have a First Amendment right to
freedom of speech but that doesn't
absolve you from all of the
repercussions of actually using that
speech in a specific way by analogy
consider a hypothetical involving
pardons now in the same way that the
president has almost unfettered foreign
policy power the president absolutely
has unfettered pardon power it can't be
checked by Congress and it can't really
be checked by the judiciary either but
if a president started selling pardons
for a million dollars apiece that
president could and pretty much by all
accounts should be impeached for that
kind of action despite the fact that the
president is allowed to pardon people
under almost any circumstances
and in fact one might argue that that
president should be criminally
prosecuted for solicitation of a bribe
so the fact that this particular
instance implicates foreign policy
should give everyone pause because the
president has wide powers here but just
because the president has wide powers
doesn't act to absolve the president of
potentially untoward activity which
brings me to the next offense which is
that the State Department or Gordon
Sandlin went rogue
I think we're gonna be seeing more of
this particular defense in the wake of
Gordon Salman's bombshell testimony but
at base Gordon Sandlin testified that in
a few calls he had but the president he
didn't explicitly link releasing the
aide with investigations into the
Biden's but that everyone knew that that
was what the president wanted that was
the understanding amongst Pompeo Volcker
and Sandlin the aka be three amigos
so potentially those three people could
be the fall guys for the administration
saying that it wasn't the president that
ordered the conditionality of the Biden
investigation on the 8th but rather
these State Department officials that
went rogue the argument being that the
president didn't order it
if the State Department officials had
that understanding it wasn't an
understanding that came from the
president and that the State Department
and the chief of staff slashed the head
of the OMB Mick Mulvaney effectively
went rogue in a coordinated effort to
extract something from the Ukrainians
that the president actually didn't want
I will leave it to you if you think that
it is more likely that these individuals
acted without the knowledge and consent
of the President or whether it was more
likely that the president gave orders
that were trickled through the Secretary
of State and chief of staff secretary
Perry ambassador Volcker and I worked
with mr. Rudy Giuliani on Ukraine
matters at the express direction of the
President of the United States now
Gordon sunland says that when Giuliani
gave orders it was assumed to have come
from the president specifically when the
president says talk to my personal
attorney and then mr. Giuliani as his
personal attorney makes certain requests
or demands we assume it's coming from
the president now one issue with this
particular defense is that Rudy Giuliani
didn't have the
authority to hold up Ukrainian aid for
almost an entire year that that falls
under the purview of the OMB that's led
by Mick Mulvaney which is one reason we
would really want to know what people
told Mick Mulvaney and why as well as
what was told to Rudy Giuliani and what
was spoken between the two of them which
brings me to the next potential defense
the president has a duty to root out
corruption both domestically and abroad
I think that this is probably the main
defense that we're going to see going
forward now as we've covered the
president controls foreign policy and
there's no doubt that rooting out
corruption is intertwined with that
mandate to deal with America's foreign
policy now based on the evidence that's
been elicited so far I leave it to you
as to whether you believe that the
president was motivated to root out
corruption abroad or whether he was
motivated to get dirt on a political
rival but note that people are
complicated and it can be both people
can be motivated by multiple different
things at the same time now in the
criminal world in terms of mens rea uh
if there are multiple reasons for
committing something if any one of those
mental states is sufficient to meet the
standard of mens rea oh that's required
that person can be convicted of that
particular crime so the underlying
argument is that if there was a basis
for the hunter Biden / corruption
argument then the president is absolved
but that actually goes the wrong way at
least when you're talking about the
criminal context if someone has
committed the act that is sufficient for
a crime say bank robbery and has
multiple reasons for doing it one of
which is the mental state that's
required for the criminal offense say
bank robbery again the fact that there
are multiple different motivations is
irrelevant if any one part of that
motivation is sufficient that person can
be convicted and again we would have to
go back to not only what the president
has said but what the president has done
and what everyone else had done around
the president to determine what the
president's mental state actually was at
the time and whether that was sufficient
to prove solicitation of bribery now
Kurt Volker testified on November 19th
that he saw investigations into burries
mo to be separate from the Biden's
the former being okay the latter being
improper quid pro quo solicitation of
bribery there was no mention of Vice
President Biden rather in referencing
burries MA and 2016 election
interference it was clear to me that he
mr. e remark was only talking about
whether any Ukrainians had acted
inappropriately he concluded that others
in the Trump administration saw the two
as intertwined and as the same if that
is indeed the case that could be
sufficient to prove solicitation of
bribery but what could be potentially
even more damning in this context and
might obviate the corruption defense is
that multiple witnesses have testified
the president Trump wasn't interested in
the investigation into the Biden so much
as the announcement of the investigation
as I think a Sheeran Gotha was the first
to point out this is what's considered
black propaganda propaganda that
obfuscates where it came from the Trump
administration wanted the Ukrainians to
make an announcement of the
investigation into the Biden's and make
it look like it had nothing to do with
the Trump administration and on top of
that it doesn't appear that the Trump
administration cared about this
corruption in 2017 or 2018 when hundreds
of millions of dollars of aid went to
the Ukrainians it was only in 2019 when
Joe Biden became the political
frontrunner for the Democrats for the
2020 election and since President Trump
asks us to read the transcript in the
transcript of the July 25th call the
president doesn't actually mention
corruption he mentions the Biden's
three times and similarly President
Trump doesn't ask about Purisima but
about the Biden's now other witnesses
may have a lot more to talk about this
that we may learn evidence that the
president was more concerned about
corruption of course as we've talked
about on this channel before there are
proper channels for opening up an
investigation into an American citizen
abroad and president Trump does not
appear to have followed any of those
procedures and of course those
procedures never involve using your own
personal attorney as a figurehead for
American foreign policy and also as
several witnesses testified foreign
policy and/or the National Security
Council is supposed to be very separate
from domestic politics so arguably it is
correct
that whatever hunter Biden may or may
not have done and whatever Joe Biden may
or may not have done isn't relevant to
the question of whether the president
engaged in some illicit action but what
is relevant is the president's
understanding of what hunter and Joe
Biden may or may not have done and I
think this is what ben shapiro was
getting at in his tweet he accurately
points out that the president's
motivations do matter in this context
that similar action can be liable or
culpable depending on the mental state
that's at issue but at the same time the
process matters to given how unusual
some of these actions are and how bad
some of them look it can be very very
difficult to make a defense that the
mental state is missing in this
particular case the process does matter
and you can't just put lipstick on a pig
by saying that something that was
completely illegal and improper was done
for the purpose of rooting out
corruption for example as law professor
Orin Kerr said very facetiously you
can't impeach Nixon for trying to
uncover corruption at the DNC's
Watergate offices it was Nixon's duty to
fight corruption and it's not his fault
that his political opponents were so
corrupt that it required him to send
burglars over to break in some might
counter that a president has better ways
to fight corruption such as sending the
FBI whose job it is to do that but Nixon
is so passionate about fighting
corruption that he felt compelled to
secretly send his own burglars loyal
only to him to get it done right it's
disgusting that some think Nixon should
be impeached simply for loving America
so much that he just wanted to
investigate corruption in the most
effective way he could you'd have to
love corruption to criticize the
Watergate break-in it was a perfect
break-in that really gets to the heart
of it the process matters and the
process also gives us a window into the
motivations that might have motivated
the particular actions at issue here now
I think I'll have to do an entirely
separate video on hunter and Joe Biden
in the potential for corruption but
suffice to say both sides could be right
at the same time there could be
underlying corruption and it could also
be the case that President Trump did
something illegal and impeachable both
could be true at the same time hunter
Biden could be the
incarnate but president Trump's axe
could still be an illegal solicitation
of a bribe they are not mutually
exclusive which is one of the reasons
why I think a lot of the president's
defenders will retreat to the position
that it's bad but it's not impeach ibly
bad this is a political question as to
whether these actions give rise to
impeachment or whether it is prudent to
conduct an impeachment under the
circumstances it's a political question
that I will leave to you but also
remember that the standard is not
whether this is a crime or not it is
whether it is an abuse of power that is
sufficient for impeachment or not and
all I'll say is that it might be a good
time to read Federalist 65 and 66
written by Alexander Hamilton which
gives a pretty good summary of why the
founders gave Congress the power to
impeach and when it's a good idea to
impeach always a good idea to read the
Federalist Papers and then of course
everything else pretty much falls into
the Chewbacca defense ladies and
gentlemen this is Chewbacca nothing
about that for one minute that does not
make thing or in other words as lawyers
like to say when you don't have the
facts pound the law when you don't have
the law pound the facts and when you
don't have the law or the facts pound
the table the funny thing is that in my
Twitter timeline I am seeing both
Democrats and Republicans using this
phrase to describe the other side so I
will leave it to you as to whether you
think that it is the Republicans who are
using the Chewbacca defense or the
Democrats are using the Chewbacca
defense and of course as Mark Twain said
history doesn't repeat but it does rhyme
and I would say that everything that is
unfolding in this impeachment inquiry
rhymes with the Nixon impeachment
proceedings and if you're not familiar
with those impeachment hearings you are
missing a huge part of the story of
course the easiest way to get up to
speed is to listen to some incredible
books on Watergate and impeachment on
audible I've actually been refreshing my
memory about Watergate by listening to
impeachment in American history it's a
fantastic book in which for experts on
American presidency review the only
three impeachment cases from history
against Andrew Johnson Richard Nixon and
Bill Clinton and explored the power and
meaning of impeachment today and you can
also listen to Neil cot y'all's
audiobook impeach the case against
Donald Trump catchy I'll wrote the
Independent Counsel statute under which
Robert Muller was appointed
and was the former acting Solicitor
General for the United States so that
book is absolutely incredible and gives
you a window into the arguments for and
against impeachment and right now
audible is giving legal eagles like you
three months of audible for just 695 a
month that's more than half off the
regular price there's going to be a lot
more impeachment news over the next
three months so it's a great time to get
an audible subscription and learn about
the history of impeachment in the United
States all you have to do is go over to
audible.com slash legal eagle which you
can click in the link below or text
legal eagle to five hundred five hundred
and clicking on the link in the
description really helps so learn how
these impeachment proceedings echo the
past and how they're new on audible just
head over to audible.com slash legal
eagle text legal eagle - 500 500 or
click the link in the description do you
agree with my analysis leave your
objections in the comments and check out
this playlist over here for all of my
other real law reviews including all of
my impeachment coverage where I will see
you in court